The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
We're talking about
generalized linear models.
And in generalized
linear models,
we generalize linear
models in two ways.
The first one is to allow
for a different distribution
for the response variables.
And the distributions
that we wanted
was the exponential family.
And this is a family
that can be generalized
over random variables
that are defined
on c or q in general,
with parameters rk.
But we're going to focus in
a very specific case when
y is a real valued
response variable, which
is the one you're used to when
you're doing linear regression.
And the parameter
theta also lives in r.
And so we're going to talk
about the canonical case.
So that's the canonical
exponential family,
where you have a density,
theta of x, which is
of the form, exponential plus.
And then, we have y,
which interacts with theta
only by taking a product.
Then, there's a term that
depends only on theta,
some dispersion parameter phi.
And then, we have some
normalization factor.
Let's call it c of y phi.
So it really should not matter
too much, so it's c of y phi,
and that's really just the
normal position factor.
And here, we're going to
assume that phi is known.
I have no idea what I write.
I don't know if
you guys can read.
I don't know what chalk
has been used today,
but I just can't see it.
That's not my fault. All
right, so we're going
to assume that phi is known.
And so we saw that
several distributions
that we know well, including
the Gaussian for example,
belong to this family.
And there's other
ones, such as Poisson--
Poisson and Bernoulli.
So if the PMF has
this form, if you
have a discrete random
variable, this is also valid.
And the reason why we
introduced this family
is because there are going to
be some properties that we know
that this thing here,
this function, b of theta,
is essentially what
completely characterizes
your distribution.
So if phi is fixed, we know that
the interaction is the form.
And this really just
comes from the fact
that we want the function
to integrate to one.
So this b here in
the canonical form
encodes everything
we want to know.
If I tell you what
b of theta is--
and of course, I
tell you what phi
is, but let's say for a second
that phi is equal to one.
If I tell you this
b of theta, you
know exactly what distribution
I'm talking about.
So it should encode
everything that's
specific to this distribution,
such as mean, variance,
all the moments
that you would want.
And we'll see how we can
compute from this thing
the mean and the
variance, for example.
So today, we're going to
talk about likelihood,
and we're going to start
with the likelihood
function or the log likelihood
for one observation.
From this, we're going
to do some computations,
and then, we'll move on to the
actual log likelihood based
on n independent observations.
And here, as we will
see, the observations
are not going to be
identically distributed,
because we're going
to want each of them,
conditionally on x to be a
different function of x, where
theta is just a
different function of x
for each of the observation.
So remember, the
log likelihood--
and this is for
one observation--
is just the log of
the density, right?
And we have this
identity that I mentioned
at the end of the
class on Tuesday.
And this identity is
just that the expectation
of the derivative of this
guy with respect to theta
is equal to 0.
So let's see why.
So if I take the derivative
with respect to theta, of log f,
theta of x, what I
get is the derivative
with respect to
theta of f, theta
of x, divided by f theta of x.
Now, if I take the
expectation of this guy,
with respect to this
theta as well, what I get
is that this thing--
what is the expectation?
Well, it's just the
integral against f theta.
Or if I'm in a
discrete case, I just
have the sum against f
theta, if it's a pmf.
Just the definition,
the expectation of x,
is either the integral--
well, let's say of h of x--
is integral of h of x.
F theta of x--
if this is discrete
or is just the sum
of h of x, f theta of x.
If x is discrete--
so if it's continuous,
you put this soft sum.
This guy is the
same thing, right?
So I'm just going to illustrate
the case when it's continuous.
So this is what?
Well, this is the integral of
partial derivative with respect
to theta, of f theta of
x, divided by f theta
of x, all time f theta of x--
dx.
And now, this f
theta is canceled,
so I'm actually left
with the integral
of the derivative,
which I'm going
to write as the derivative
of the integral.
But f theta being density
for any value of theta
that I can take,
this is the function.
As a function of
theta, this function
is constantly equal to 1.
For any theta that I take
it, it takes value of 1.
So this is constantly
equal to 1.
I put three bars to see
that for any value of theta,
this is 1, which actually
tells me that the derivative is
equal to 0.
OK, yes?
AUDIENCE: What is
the first [INAUDIBLE]
that you wrote on the board?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: That's
just the definition
of the derivative of
the log of a function?
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Log of
f prime is f prime over f.
That's a log, yeah.
Just by elimination.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: When you write a
squiggle that starts with an l,
I assume it's lambda.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: And you do
good, because that's probably
how my mind processes.
And so I'm like, yeah, l.
Here is enough information.
OK, everybody is good with this?
So that was convenient.
So it just said
that the expectation
of the derivative of the log
likelihood is equal to 0.
That's going to be
our first identity.
Let's move onto the
second identity,
using exactly the same
trick, which is let's hope
that at some point,
we have the integral
of this function
that's constantly
equal to 1 as a function of
theta, and then use the fact
that its derivative
is equal to 0.
So if I start taking the
second derivative of the log
of f theta, so what is this?
Well, it's the
derivative of this guy
here, so I'm going
to go straight to it.
So it's second derivative,
f theta of x, times
f theta of x, minus first
derivative of f theta of x,
times first derivative
of f theta of x.
Here is some super
important stuff--
no, I'm kidding.
So you can still see
that guy over there?
So it's just the square.
And then, I divide by
f theta of x squared.
So here I have the second
derivative, times f itself.
And here, I have the product
of the first derivative
with itself.
So that's the square.
So now, I'm going to
integrate this guy.
So if I take the expectation
of this thing here, what I get
is the integral.
So here, the only
thing that's going
to happen when I'm going
to take my integral
is that one of those
squares is going to cancel
against f theta, right?
So I'm going to get
the second derivative
minus the second
derivative squared.
And then, I'm
divided by f theta.
And I know that this
thing is equal to 0.
Now, one of these guys here--
sorry, why do I have--
so I have this guy here.
So this guy here
is going to cancel.
So this is what
this is equal to--
the integral of the partial,
so the second derivative of f
theta of x, because
those two guys cancel--
minus the integral of
the second derivative.
And this is telling me what?
Yeah, I'm losing one, because
I have some weird sequences.
Thank you.
OK, this is still positive.
I want to say that this
thing is actually equal to 0.
But then, it gives
me some weird things,
which are that I
have an integral
of a positive function,
which is equal to 0.
Yeah, that's what I'm
thinking of doing.
But I'm going to get 0 for
this entire integral, which
means that I have the integral
of a positive function, which
is equal to 0, which means that
this function is equal to 0,
which sounds a little bad--
basically, tells me that this
function, f theta, is linear.
So I went a little
too far, I believe,
because I only want to
prove that the expectation
of the second derivative--
Yes, so I want to pull this out.
So let's see, if I keep rolling
with this, I'm going to get--
well, no because the fact
that it's divided by f theta,
means that, indeed, the second
derivative is equal to 0.
So it cannot do this here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: OK, but
let's write it like this.
You're right, so this is what?
This is the expectation of
the partial with respect
to theta of f
theta of x, divided
by f theta of x squared.
And this is exactly the
derivative of the log, right?
So indeed, this thing is equal
to the expectation with respect
to theta of the partial of l--
of log f theta, divided
by partial theta.
All right, so this is one of
the guys that I want squared.
This is one of the
guys that I want.
And this is actually
equal, so this will
be equal to the expectation--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh, right, so
this term should be equal to 0.
This was not 0.
You're absolutely right.
So at some point,
I got confused,
because I thought
putting this equal to 0
would mean that this is 0.
But this thing is
not equal to 0.
So this thing, you're right.
I take the same trick as
before, and this is actually
equal to 0, which
means that now I have
what's on the left-hand side,
which is equal to what's
on the right-hand side.
And if I recap, I
get that e theta
of the second derivative
of the log of f theta
is equal to minus--
because I had a
minus sign here--
to the expectation with respect
to theta, of log of f theta,
divided by theta squared.
Thank you for being on watch
when I'm falling apart.
All right, so this
is exactly what
you have here, except
that both terms have
been put on the same side.
All right, so those things
are going to be useful to us,
so maybe, we should write
them somewhere here.
And then, we have
that the expectation
of the second
derivative of the log
is equal to minus the
expectation of the square
of the first derivative.
And this is, indeed,
my Fisher information.
This is just telling me what is
the second derivative of my log
likelihood at theta, right?
So everything is
with respect to theta
when I take these expectations.
And so it tells me
that the expectation
of the second derivative--
at least first of all, what
it's telling me is
that it's concave,
because the second
derivative of this thing,
which is the second
derivative of kl divergence,
is actually minus something
which is must be non-negative.
And so it's telling me
that it's concave here
at this [INAUDIBLE].
And in particular,
it's also telling me
that it has to be strictly
positive, unless the derivative
of f is equal to 0.
Unless f is constant, then
it's not going to change.
All right, do you
have a question?
So now, let's use this.
So what does my
log likelihood look
like when I actually compute it
for this canonical exponential
family.
We have this exponential
function, so taking the log
should make my life much
easier, and indeed, it does.
So if I look at the
canonical, what I have
is that the log of f
theta of x, it's equal
simply to y theta minus b
of theta, divided by phi,
plus this function that
does not depend on theta.
So let's see what this tells me.
Let's just plug-in those
equalities in there.
I can take the derivative
of the right-hand side
and just say that in
expectation, it's equal to 0.
So if I start looking
at the derivative,
this is equal to what?
Well, here I'm going
to pick up only y.
Sorry, this is a function of y.
I was talking about
likelihood, so I actually
need to put the
random variable here.
So I get y minus the
derivative of b of theta.
Since it's only a
function of theta,
I'm just going to write
b prime, is at OK--
rather than having the
partial with respect to theta.
Then, this is a constant.
This does not depend on
theta, so it goes away.
So if I start taking the
expectation of this guy,
I get the expectation
of this guy,
which is the expectation
of y, minus-- well,
this does not depend on
y, so it's just itself--
b prime of theta.
And the whole thing
is divided by phi.
But from my first
equality over there,
I know that this thing
is actually equal to 0.
We just proved that.
So in particular, it means
that since phi is non-zero,
it means that this guy
must be equal to this guy--
or phi is not infinity.
And so that implies
that the expectation
with respect to theta of y
is equal to b prime of theta.
I'm sorry, you're not
registered in this class.
I'm going to have
to ask you to leave.
I'm not kidding.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: You are?
I've never seen you here.
I saw you for the first lecture.
OK.
All right, so e theta of y
is equal to b prime of theta.
Everybody agrees with that?
So this is actually nice,
because if I give you
an exponential family, the only
thing I really need to tell
you is what b theta is.
And if I give you b of theta,
then computing a derivative
is actually much easier
than having to integrate y
against the density itself.
You could really
have fun and try
to compute this, which you
would be able to do, right?
And then, there's the plus c
of y phi, blah, blah, blah--
dy.
And that's the way you would
actually compute this thing.
Sorry, this guy is here.
That would be painful.
I don't know what this
normalization looks like,
so it would have to
also explicit that,
so I can actually
compute this thing.
And you know, just
the same way, if you
want to compute the
expectation of a Gaussian--
well, the expectation
of a Gaussian
is not the most difficult one.
But even if you compute the
expectation of a Poisson,
you start to have to
work in a little bit.
There's a few things that
you have to work through.
Here, I'm just telling
you, all you have to know
is what b of theta
is, and then, you
can just take the derivative.
Let's see what the second
equality is going to give us.
OK, so what is the
second equality?
It's telling me that if I
look at the second derivative,
and then I take its
expectation, I'm
going to have something which
is equal to negative this guy
squared.
Sorry, that was the log, right?
We've already computed
this first derivative
of the likelihood.
It's just the expectation of
the square of this thing here.
So expectation of
the derivative,
with respect to theta of
log, f theta of x, divided
by partial theta squared.
This is equal to the
expectation of the square of y,
minus b theta, divided
by phi squared--
b prime, theta squared.
OK, sorry, I'm actually
going to move on with the--
so if I start computing,
what is this thing?
Well, we just agreed
that this was what?
The expectation of theta, right?
So that's just the
expectation of y.
We just computed it here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, that's b prime.
There's a derivative here.
So now, this is what?
This is simply-- anyone?
I'm sorry?
Variance of y, but you're
scaling by phi squared.
OK, so this is negative
of the right-hand side
of our inequality.
And now, I just have to take
one more derivative to this guy.
So now, if I look at
the left-hand side now,
I have that the
second derivative
of log, of f theta of y, divided
by partial of theta squared.
So this thing is equal to--
well, no, I'm not
left with much.
The white part is
going to go away,
and I'm left only with the
second derivative of theta,
minus the second derivative
theta, divided by phi.
So if I take expectation--
well, it just doesn't change.
This is deterministic.
So now, what I've
established is that this guy
is equal to negative this guy.
So those two things, the
signs are going to go away.
And so this implies
that the variance of y
is equal to b prime prime theta.
And then, I have a phi
square in denominator
that cancels only one of the
phi squares, so it's time phi.
So now, I have that my second
derivative-- since I know phi
is completely
determining the variance.
So basically, that's why b is
called the cumulant generating
function.
It's not generating
moments, but cumulants.
But cumulants, in this
case, correspond, basically,
to the moments, at
least for the first two.
If I start going
farther, I'm going
to have more combinations of
the expectation of y3, y2,
and y itself.
But as we know,
those are the ones
that are usually the
most useful, at least
if we're interested in
asymptotic performance.
The central limit
theorem tells us
that all that matters are
the first two moments,
and then, the rest is just
going to go and say well,
it doesn't matter.
It's all going to
[INAUDIBLE] anyway.
So let's go to a
Poisson for example.
So if I had a Poisson
distribution--
so this is a discrete
distribution.
And what I know is that f--
let me call mu the
parameter of y.
So it's mu to the y, divided
by y factorial, exponential
minus mu.
OK so mu is usually
called lambda,
and y is usually
called x, that's
why it takes me to a
little bit of time.
But it usually it's
lambda to the x over
factorial x, exponential
minus lambda.
Since this is just the series
expansion of the exponential
when I sum those things
from 0 to infinity,
this thing sums to 1.
But then, if I wanted to
start understanding what
the expectation
of this thing is--
so if I want to understand
the expectation with respect
to mu of y, then, I would
have to compute the sum
from k equals 0 to infinity
of k, times mu to the k,
over factorial of k,
exponential minus mu--
which means that I
would, essentially,
have to take the derivative
of my series in the end.
So I can do this.
This is a standard exercise.
You've probably done it
when you took probability.
But let's see if we can
actually just read it off
from the first derivative of b.
So to do that, we
need to write this
in the form of an
exponential, where there
is one parameter that captures
mu, that interacts with y, just
doing this parameter times
y, and then something that
depends only on y, and then
something that depends only
on mu.
That's the important one.
That's going to be
our B. And then,
there's going to be something
that depends only on y.
So let's write this and
check that this f mu, indeed,
belongs to this canonical
exponential family.
So I definitely
have an exponential
that comes from this guy.
So I have minus mu.
And then, this thing is
going to give me what?
It's going to give
me plus y log mu.
And then, I'm going to have
minus log of y factorial.
So clearly, I have a
term that depends only
on mu, terms that
depend only on y,
and I have a product of y and
something that depends on mu.
If I want to be
canonical, I must
have this to be exactly
the parameter theta itself.
So I'm going to
call this guy theta.
So theta is log mu,
which means that mu
is equal to e to the theta.
And so wherever I
see mu, I'm going
to replace it by [INAUDIBLE] the
theta, because my new parameter
now, is theta.
So this is what?
This is equal to
exponential y times theta.
And then, I'm going to
have minus e of theta.
And then, who cares, something
that depends only on mu.
So this is my c of y, and phi
is equal to 1 in this case.
So that's all I care about.
So let's use it.
So this is my canonical
exponential family.
Y interacts with theta
exactly like this.
And then, I have this function.
So this function here
must be b of theta.
So from this function,
exponential theta,
I'm supposed to be able
to read what the mean is.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Because
since in this course
I always know what
the dispersion is,
I can actually always absorb
it into theta from one.
But here, it's really of
the form y times something
divided by 1, right?
If it was like log
of mu divided by phi,
that would be the
question of whether I
want to call phi my
dispersion, or if I
want to just have it in there.
This makes no
difference in practice.
But the real thing
is it's never going
to happen that this
thing, this version,
is going to be an exact number.
If it's an actual
numerical number,
this just means that this
number should be absorbed
in the definition of theta.
But if it's something
that is called sigma, say,
and I will assume
that sigma is known,
then it's probably preferable
to keep it in the dispersion,
so you can see that
there's this parameter here
that you can,
essentially, play with.
It doesn't make any
difference when you know phi.
So now, if I look at the
expectation of some y-- so now,
I'm going to have y, which
follows my Poisson mu.
I'm going to look
at the expectation,
and I know that the expectation
is b prime of theta.
Agreed?
That's what I just
erased, I think.
Agreed with this,
the derivative?
So what is this?
Well, it's the derivative
of e to the theta, which
is e to the theta, which is mu.
So my Poisson is
parametrized by its mean.
I can also compute
the variance, which
is equal to minus the
second derivative of--
no, it's equal to the
second derivative of b.
Dispersion is equal to 1.
Again, if I took phi elsewhere,
I would see it here as well.
So if I just absorbed phi here,
I would see it divided here,
so it would not
make any difference.
And what is the second
derivative of the exponential?
Still the exponential--
so it's still equal to mu.
So that certainly
makes our life easier.
Just one quick from remark--
here's the function.
I am giving you problem--
can the b function--
can it ever be equal
to log of theta?
Who says yes?
Who says no?
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, so
what I've learned from this--
it's sort of completely
analytic, right?
So we just took derivatives,
and this thing just happened.
This thing actually allowed us
to relate the second derivative
of b to the variance.
And one thing that we
know about a variance
is that this is non-negative.
And in particular,
it's always positive.
If they give you a canonical
exponential family that
has zero variance, trust
me, you will see it.
That means that
this thing is not
going to look like
something that's finite,
and it's going to
have a point mass.
It's going to take value
infinity at one point.
So this will,
basically, never happen.
This thing is, actually,
strictly positive,
which means that this thing
is always strictly concave.
It means that the second
derivative of this function, b,
has to be strictly positive, and
so that the function is convex.
So this is concave, so this
is definitely not working.
I need to have something
that looks like this
when I talk about my b.
So f theta squared--
we'll see a bunch of
exponential theta.
And there's a bunch of them.
But if you started writing
something, and you find b--
try to think of the
plot of b in your mind,
and you find that b looks like
it's going to become concave,
you've made a sign
mistake somewhere.
All right, so we've done
a pretty big parenthesis
to try to characterize
what the distribution of y
was going to be.
We wanted to extend from, say,
Gaussian to something else.
But when we're doing
regression, which
means generalized
linear models, we
are not interested in
the distribution of y
but really the conditional
distribution of y given x.
So I need now to couple
those back together.
So what I know is that
this same mu, in this case,
which is the expectation--
what I want to say is that
the conditional
expectation of y given x--
this is some mu of x.
When we did linear
models, we said well,
this thing was some x transpose
beta for linear models.
And the whole premise
of this chapter
is to say well, this
might make no sense,
because x transpose beta
can take the entire range
of real values.
Whereas, this mu can take
only a partial range.
So even if you actually focus
on the Poisson, for example,
we know that the expectation
of a Poisson has to be
a non-negative number--
actually, a positive
number as soon as you
have a little bit of variance.
It's mu itself-- mu
is a positive number.
And so it's not going
to make any sense
to assume that mu of x is
equal to x transpose beta,
because you might find some x's
for which this value ends up
being negative.
And so we're going
to need, what we
call, the link
function that relates,
that transforms mu,
maps onto the real line,
so that you can now express it
of the form x transpose beta.
So we're going to take
not this, but we're
going to assume
that g of mu of x
is not equal to
x transpose beta,
and that's the
generalized linear models.
So as I said, it's weird to
transform x transpose beta--
a mu to make it
take the real line.
At least to me, it
feels a bit more
natural to take x
transpose beta and make
it fit to the particular
distribution that I want.
And so I'm going to want to
talk about g and g inverse
at the same time.
So I'm going to
actually take always g.
So g is my link
function, and I'm
going to want g to be
continuous differentiable.
OK, let's say that
it has a derivative,
and its derivative
is continuous.
And I'm going to want g
to be strictly increasing.
And that actually implies
that g inverse exists.
Actually, that's not true.
What I'm also going to want
is that g of mu spans--
how do I do this?
So I want the g, as I arrange
for all possible values of mu,
whether they're all
positive values,
or whether they're
values that are limited
between the intervals 0,
1, I want those to span
the entire real line, so that
when I want to talk about g
inverses define over
the entire real line,
I know where I started.
So this implies that
gene inverse exists.
What else does it
imply about g inverse?
So for a function
to be invertible,
I only need for it to
be strictly monotone.
I don't need it to be
strictly increasing.
So in particular, the fact
that I picked increasing
implies that this guy
is actually increasing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's the image.
So this is my link function, and
this slide is just telling me
I want my function
to be invertible,
so I can talk about g inverse.
I'm going to switch
between the two.
So what link functions
am I going to get?
So for linear
models, we just said
there's no link
function, which is
the same as saying that the
link function is identity,
which certainly satisfies
all these conditions.
It's invertible.
It has all these
nice properties,
but might as well
not talk about it.
For Poisson data,
when we assume that
the conditional distribution
of y given x is Poisson,
the mu, as I just said, is
required to be positive.
So I need a g that goes
from the interval 0 infinity
to the entire real line.
I need a function that
starts from one end
and just takes-- not
only the positive values
are split between positive
and negative values.
And here, for example, I
could take the log link.
So the log is defined
on this entire interval.
And as I range from
0 to plus infinity,
the log is ranging from negative
infinity to plus infinity.
You can probably think
of other functions
that do that, like 2 times log.
That's another one.
But there's many others
you can think of.
But let's say the
log is one of them
that you might want
to think about.
It is unnatural in
the sense that it's
one of the first
function we can think of.
We will see, also, that it has
another canonical property that
makes it a natural choice.
The other one is
the other example,
where we had an even stronger
condition on what mu could be.
Mu could only be a
number between 0 and 1,
that was the probability
of success of a coin flip--
probability of success of a
Bernoulli random variable.
And now, I need g to map 0,
1 to the entire real line.
And so here are
a bunch of things
that you can come up
with, because now you
start to have maybe--
I will soon claim that
this one, log of mu,
divided by 1 minus mu
is the most natural one.
But maybe, if you had
never thought of this,
that might not be
the first function
you would come up with, right?
You mentioned trigonometric
functions, for example,
so maybe, you can
come up with something
that comes from hyperbolic
trigonometry or something.
So what does this function do?
Well, we'll see a picture,
but this function does
map the interval 0, 1
to the entire real line.
We also discuss the fact that
if we think reciprocally--
what I want if I want to
think about g inverse,
I want a function that maps the
entire real line into the unit
interval.
And as we said, if I'm not
a very creative statistician
or probabilist, I can just
pick my favorite continuous,
strictly increasing cumulative
distribution function,
which as we know,
will arise as soon
as I have a density
that has support
on the entire real line.
If I have support everywhere,
then it means that my--
it is strictly positive
everywhere, then,
it means that my community
distribution function
has to be strictly increasing.
And of course, it has to go
from 0 to 1, because that's just
the nature of those things.
And so for example, I
can take the Gaussian,
that's one such function.
But I could also take
the double exponential
that looks like an
exponential on one end,
and then an exponential
on the other end.
And basically, if you
take capital phi, which
is the standard Gaussian
cumulative distribution
function, it does work for you,
and you can take its inverse.
And in this case,
we don't talk about,
so this guy is called
logit or logit.
And this guy is called probit.
And you see it,
usually, every time
you have a package on
generalized linear models.
You are trying to implement.
You have this choice.
And for what's called logistic
regression-- so it's funny
that it's called
logistic regression,
but you can actually
use the probit link,
which in this case, is
called probit regression.
But those things are
essentially equivalent,
and it's really a
matter of taste.
Maybe of communities--
some communities
might prefer one over the other.
We'll see that
again, as I claimed
before, the logistic,
the logit one
has a slightly more compelling
argument for its reason
to exist.
I guess this one, the
compelling argument
is that it involved the
standard Gaussian, which
of course, is something that
should show up everywhere.
And then, you can think
about crazy stuff.
Even crazy gets name--
complimentary log, log, which is
the log of minus, log 1 minus.
Why not?
So I guess you can
iterate that thing.
You can just put a log 1
minus in front of this thing,
and it's still going to go.
So that's not true.
I have to put a minus and take--
no, that's not true.
So you can think of
whatever you want.
So I claimed that the logit
link is the natural choice, so
here's a picture.
I should have actually
plotted the other one,
so we can actually compare it.
To be fair, I don't even
remember how it would actually
fit into those two functions.
So the blue one, which is
this one, for those of you
don't see the difference
between blue and red--
sorry about that.
So this the blue one
is the logistic one.
So this guy is the function that
does e to the x, over 1 plus
e to the x.
As you can see,
this is a function
that's supposed to map
the entire real line
into the intervals, 0, 1.
So that's supposed to be the
inverse of your function,
and I claimed that this is
the inverse of the logistic
of the logit function.
And the blue one, well,
this is the Gaussian CDF,
so you know it's clearly
the inverse of the inverse
of the Gaussian CDF.
And that's the red one.
That's the one that goes here.
I would guess that the
complimentary log, log is
something that's probably
going above here,
and for which the
slope is, actually,
even a little flatter
as you cross 0.
So of course, this is
not our link functions.
These are the inverse
of our link function.
So what do they look
like when actually,
basically, flip my
thing like this?
So this is what I see.
And so I can see that in blue,
this is my logistic link.
So it crosses 0 with a
slightly faster rate.
Remember, if we could
use the identity, that
would be very nice to us.
We would just want
to take the identity.
The problem is that
if I start having
the identity that
goes here, it's
going to start being a problem.
And this is the probit link,
the phi verse that you see here.
It's a little flatter.
You can compute the derivative
at zero of those guys.
What is the derivative of the--
So I'm taking the derivative
of log of x over 1 minus x.
So it's 1 over x,
minus 1 over 1 minus x.
So if I look at 0.5--
sorry, this is
the interval 0, 1.
So I'm interested
in the slope at 0.5.
Yes, it's plus, thank you.
So at 0.5, what I
get is 2 plus 2.
Yeah, so that's the
slope that we get,
and if you compute
for the derivative--
what is the derivative
of a phi inverse?
Well, it's a little
phi of x, divided
by little phi of capital
phi, inverse of x.
So little phi at 1/2--
I don't know.
Yeah, I guess I can
probably compute
the derivative of
the capital phi
at 0, which is going
to be just that.
1 over square root of 2
pi, and then just say well,
the slope has to be 1 over that.
Square root 2 pi.
So that's just a comparison,
but again, so far, we
do not have any reason to
prefer one to the other.
And so now, I'm going to
start giving you some reasons
to prefer one to the other.
And one of those two--
and actually for each
canonical family,
there is something which is
called the canonical link.
And when you don't
have any other reason
to choose anything else, why
not choose the canonical one?
And the canonical
link is the one
that says OK, what I want is g
to map mu onto the real line.
But mu is not the parameter
of my canonical family.
Here for example,
mu is e of theta,
but the canonical
parameter is theta.
But the parameter of a
canonical exponential family
is something that lives
in the entire real line.
It was defined for all thetas.
And so in particular,
I can just take theta
to be the one that's
x transpose beta.
And so in particular,
I'm just going
to try to find the link
that just says OK, when
I take g of mu,
I'm going to map,
so that's what's going to be.
So I know that g of mu is
going to be equal to x beta.
And now, what I'm
going to say is OK,
let's just take the g that
makes this guy equal to theta,
so that this is theta
that actually model,
like x transpose beta.
Feels pretty canonical, right?
What else?
What other central, easy
choice would you take?
This was pretty easy.
There is a natural parameter
for this canonical family,
and it takes value on
the entire real line.
I have a function that maps
mu onto the entire real line,
so let's just map it to
the actual parameter.
So now, OK, why do I have this?
Well, we've already
figured that out.
The canonical link function
is strictly increasing.
Sorry, so I said that
now I want this guy--
so I want g of mu to
be equal to theta,
which is equivalent to
saying that I want mu to be
equal to g inverse of theta.
But we know that mu is what--
b prime of theta.
So that means that b prime is
the same function as g inverse.
And I claimed that this is
actually giving me, indeed,
a function that has the
properties that I want,
because before I said,
just pick any function that
has these properties.
And now, I'm giving
you a very hard rule
to pick this, though
you need still
to check that it satisfies
those conditions and particular,
that it's increasing
and invertible.
And so for this to be
increasing and invertible,
strictly increasing
and invertible,
really what I need is that
the inverse is strictly
increasing and invertible,
which is the case here,
because b prime as we said--
well, b prime is the derivative
of a strictly convex function.
A strictly convex function
has a second derivative
that's strictly positive.
We just figured that
out using the fact
that the variance was
strictly positive.
And if phi is strictly
positive, then this thing
has to be strictly positive.
So if b prime, prime
is strictly positive--
this is the derivative of
a function called b prime.
If your derivative
is strictly positive,
you are strictly increasing.
And so we know that b prime is,
indeed, strictly increasing.
And what I need also
to check-- well,
I guess this is already
checked on its own,
because b prime is
actually mapping all of our
into the possible values.
When theta ranges on
the entire real line,
then b prime ranges
in the entire interval
of the mean values
that it can take.
And so now, I have this thing
that's completely defined.
B prime inverse is a valid link.
And it's called
a canonical link.
OK, so again, if I give you
an exponential family, which
is another way of saying I'll
give you a convex function, b,
which gives you some
exponential family,
then if you just
take b prime inverse,
this gives you the
associated canonical link
for this canonical
exponential family.
So clearly there's
an advantage of doing
this, which is I don't
have to actually think
about which one to pick if I
don't want to think about it.
But there's other
advantages that come to it,
and we'll see that in
the representations.
There's, basically, going to be
some light cancellations that
show up.
So before we go
there, let's just
compute the canonical link for
the Bernoulli distribution.
So remember, the
Bernoulli distribution
has a PMF, which is part of the
canonical exponential family.
So the PMF of the
Bernoulli is f theta of x.
Let me just write it like this.
So it's p to the y,
let's say-- one minus p
to the 1 minus y,
which I will write
as exponential y log p, plus
1 minus y, log 1 minus p.
OK, we've done that last time.
Now, I'm going to
group my terms in y
to see how y interacts
with this parameter p.
And what I'm getting is
y, which is times log p
divided by 1 minus p.
And then, the only term that
remains is log, 1 minus p.
Now, I want this to be a
canonical exponential family,
which means that I just
need to call this guy,
so it is part of the
exponential family.
You can read that.
If I want it to be canonical,
this guy must be theta itself.
So I have that theta is
equal to log p, 1 minus p.
If I invert this
thing, it tells me
that p is e to the theta,
divided by 1, plus e
to the theta.
It's just inverting
this function.
In particular, it means
that log, 1 minus p,
is equal to log, 1
minus this thing.
So the exponential
thetas go away.
So in the numerator,
this is what I get.
That's the log 1 minus this guy,
which is equal to minus log 1,
plus e to the theta.
So I'm going a bit too
fast, but these are
very elementary manipulations--
maybe, it requires one more
line to convince yourself.
But just do it in the
comfort of your room.
And then, what you have is the
exponential of y times theta,
and then, I have minus
log, 1 plus e theta.
So this is the
representation of the p
and f of a Bernoulli
distribution,
as part of a member of the
canonical exponential family.
And it tells me that b of
theta is equal to log 1,
plus e of theta.
That's what I have there.
From there, I can compute the
expectation, which hopefully,
I'm going to get p as
the mean and p times 1,
minus p as the variance.
Otherwise, that would be weird.
So let's just do this.
B prime of theta should
give me the mean.
And indeed, b prime of
theta is e to the theta,
divided by 1, plus e to
the theta, which is exactly
this p that I had there.
OK just for fun--
well, I don't know.
Maybe, that's not part of it.
Yeah, let's not compute
the second derivative.
That's probably going to be on
your homework at some point--
if not, on the final.
So b prime now--
oh, I erased it, of course.
G, the canonical link
is b prime inverse.
And I claim that this
is going to give me
the logit function, log
of mu, over 1 minus mu.
So let's check that.
So b prime is this
thing, so now,
I want to find the inverse.
Well, I should really call
my inverse a function of p.
And I've done it before--
all I have to do is to
solve this equation, which
I've actually just
done it, that's
where I'm actually coming from.
So it's actually telling me
that the solution of this thing
is equal to log of
p over 1 minus p.
We just solve this
thing both ways.
And this is, indeed, logit
of p by definition of logit.
So b prime inverse,
this function that
seemed to come out
of nowhere, is really
just the inverse of b
prime, which we know
is the canonical link.
And canonical is some
sort of ad hoc choices
that we've made by saying let's
just take the link, such that d
of mu is giving me the actual
canonical parameter of theta.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: You're right.
Now, of course, I'm going
through all this trouble,
but you could see
it immediately.
I know this is
going to be theta.
We also have prior
knowledge, hopefully,
that the expectation of
a Bernoulli is p itself.
So right at this
step, when I say
that I'm going to take
theta to be this guy,
already knew that the
canonical link was the logit--
because I just said
oh, here's theta.
And it's just this
function of mu [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, so you can do that
for a bunch of examples,
and this is what they're
going to give you.
So the Gaussian
case, b of theta--
we've actually computed
it, actually, once.
This is theta squared over 2.
So the derivative of
this thing is really
just theta, which means that
g or g inverse is actually
equal to the identity.
And again, sanity check--
when I'm in the
Gaussian case, there's
nothing general about
general linear models
if you don't have a link.
The Poisson case-- you
can actually check.
Did we do this, actually?
Yes we did.
So that's when we
had this e of theta.
And so b is e of theta, which
means that the natural link is
the inverse, which is log, which
is the inverse of exponential.
And so that's logarithm
link, which as I said,
I used the word natural.
You can also use
the word canonical
if you want to describe
this function as being
the right function to map
the positive real line
to the entire real line.
The Bernoulli-- we just did it.
So b-- the cumulative
enduring function is log of 1,
plus e of theta, which is
log of mu over 1 minus mu.
And gamma function--
where you have
the thing you're going to see is
minus log of minus [INAUDIBLE]..
You see the reciprocal link
is the link that actually
shows up, so minus 1 over mu.
That maps.
So are there any questions
about the canonical links,
canonical families?
I use the word canonical a lot.
But is everything fitting
together right now?
So we have this function.
We have canonical exponential
family, by assumption.
It has a function,
b, which contains
every information we want.
At the beginning
of the lecture, we
established that
it has information
about the mean in
the first derivative,
about the variance in
the second derivative.
And it's also giving
us a canonical link.
So just cherish this b
once you've found it,
because it's
everything you need.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I don't
know, a political preference?
I don't know, honestly.
If I were a serious
practitioner,
I probably would have a
better answer for you.
At this point, I just don't.
I think it's a
matter of practice
and actual preferences.
You can also try both.
We didn't mention
it, but there's
this idea of
cross-validation-- well,
we mentioned it without
going too much into detail.
But you could try both
and see which one performs
best on a yet unseen data set.
In terms of prediction, just say
I prefer this one of the two,
because this actually comes
as part of your modeling
assumption, right?
Not only did you decide
to model the image of mu
through the link function as
a linear model, but really
what you're saying--
your model is saying
well, you have
two pieces of [INAUDIBLE],,
the distribution of y.
But you also have
the fact that mu
is modeled as g inverse
of x transpose beta.
And for different g's, this
is just different modeling
assumptions, right?
So why should this be linear--
I don't know.
My authority as a
person who has not
examined the
[INAUDIBLE] data sets
for both things would be that
the changes are fairly minor.
OK, so this was all
for one observation.
We just, basically,
did probability.
We described some density, some
properties of the densities,
how to compute expectations.
That was really
just probability.
There was no data
involved at any point.
We did a bit of modeling, but
it was all for one observation.
What we're going
to try to do now
is given the reverse
engineering to probability
that is statistics,
given data, what
can I infer about my model?
Now remember, there's
three parameters
that are floating
around in this model.
There is one that was theta.
There is one that was mu, and
there is one that is beta.
OK, so those are
the three parameters
that are floating around.
What we said is that the
expectation of y, given x,
is mu of x.
So if I estimate mu, I know the
conditional expectation of y,
given x, which definitely
gives me theta of x.
How do I go from mu
of x to theta of x?
The inverse of what--
of the arrow?
Yeah, sure, but how do I go
from this guy to this guy?
So theta as a function of mu is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, so we just
computed that mu was
b prime of theta.
So it means that theta is
just b prime inverse of mu.
So those two things
are the same as far
as we're concerned, because we
know that b prime is strictly
increasing it's invertible.
So it's just a matter
of re-parametrization,
and we just can switch from one
to the other whenever we want.
But why we go through
mu, because so far
for the entire
semester I told you
there was one
parameter that's theta.
It does not have to be the
mean, and that's the parameter
that we care about.
It's the one on which we
want to do interference.
That's the one for which we're
going to compute the Fisher
information.
This was the parameter that
was our object of worship.
And now, I'm saying
oh, I'm going to have
mu that's coming around.
And why we have mu,
because this is the mu
that we use to go to beta.
So I can go freely from theta
to mu using b prime or b
prime inverse.
And now, I can go
from mu to beta,
because I have that g of mu
of x is beta transpose x.
So in the end,
now, this is going
to be my object of worship.
This is going to be the
parameter that matters.
Because once I set beta,
I set everything else
through this chain.
So the question is if I
start stacking up this pile
of parameters-- so I
start with my beta,
which in turns give me
a mu, which in turn,
gives me a theta--
can I just have a
long, streamlined--
what is the outcome
when I actually
start writing my likelihood,
not as a function of theta,
not as a function of mu,
but as a function of beta,
which is the one at
the end of the chain?
And hopefully, things are
going to happen nicely,
and they might no.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Is G--
that's my link.
G of mu of x--
now, its mu is a function of x,
because its conditional on x.
So this is really
theta of x, mu of x,
but b is not a function of x,
because it's just something
to tells me what the
function of x is.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Mu is
the conditional expectation
of y, given x.
It has, actually, a fancy name
in the statistics literature.
It's called-- anybody knows
the name of the function, mu
of x, which is a conditional
expectation of y, given x?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: That's
the regression function.
That's actual definition.
If I tell you what is the
definition of the regression
function, that's just the
conditional expectation
of why, given x.
And I could look at any property
of the conditional distribution
of y given x.
I could look at the
conditional 95th percentile.
I can look at the
conditional median.
I can look at the conditional
[INAUDIBLE] range.
I can look at the
conditional variance.
But I decide to look at the
conditional expectation, which
is called the
regression function.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh,
there's no transpose here.
Actually, only Victor-Emmanuel
used this prime for transpose,
and I found it confusing
with the derivatives.
So primes here is
only a derivative.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh, yeah,
sorry, beta transpose x.
So you said what?
I said that g of mu of
x is beta transpose x?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Isn't
that the same thing?
X is a vector here, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So x transpose beta,
and beta transpose x
are of the same thing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
beta looks like this.
X looks like this.
It's just a simple number.
Yeah, you're right.
I'm going to start
to look at matrices.
I'm going to have to be slightly
more careful when I do this.
OK so let's do the
reverse engineering.
I'm giving you data.
From this data,
hopefully, you should
be able to get what the
conditional-- if I give you
an infinite amount of data,
you would know exactly,
of pairs xy, what the
conditional distribution of y
given x is.
And in particular,
you would know
what the conditional
expectation of y given x
is, which means that
you would know mu,
which means that you
would know theta, which
means that you would know beta.
Now, when I have a finite
number of observations,
I'm going to try to
estimate mu of x.
But really, I'm going to
go the other way around.
Because the fact that I assume,
specifically, that mu of x
is of the form g of mu of x
is x transpose beta, then that
means that I only have
to estimate beta, which
is a much simpler object than
the entire regression function.
So that's what I'm
going to go for.
I'm going to try to represent
the likelihood, the log
likelihood, of my data as
a function, not of theta,
not of mu, but of beta--
and then, maximize that guy.
So now, rather than thinking
of just one observation,
I'm going to have a
bunch of observations.
So this might actually
look a little confusing,
but let's just make sure
that we understand each other
before we go any further.
So I'm going to
have observations,
x1, y1, all the
way to xn, yn, just
like in a natural
regression problem,
except that here my y's
might be 0 one valued.
They might be positive valued.
They might be exponential.
They might be anything in the
canonical exponential family.
OK so I have this
thing, and now,
what I have is that my
observations are x1,
y1, xn, yn.
And what I want
is that I'm going
to assume that the conditional
expectation of yi, given--
the conditional distribution
of yi, given xi,
is something that has density.
Did I put an i on y-- yeah.
I'm not going to deal with
the phi and the c now.
And why do I have
theta i and not theta
is because theta i is
really a function of xi.
So it's really theta i of xi.
But what do I know
about theta i of xi,
it's actually equal to b--
I did this error twice--
b prime inverse of mu of xi.
And I'm going to assume that
this is of the form beta
transpose xi.
And this is why I have theta i--
is because this theta
i is a function of xi,
and I'm going to assume a very
simple form for this thing.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry--
I should not write it like this.
This is only when I
have the canonical link.
So this is actually equal
to b prime inverse of g,
of xi transpose beta.
Sorry, g inverse--
those two things
are actually
canceling each other.
So as before, I'm going to
stack everything into some--
well, actually, I'm not going to
stack anything for the moment.
I'm just going to give
you a peek at what's
happening next week, rather
than just manipulating the data.
So here is how we're going
to proceed at this point.
Well now, I want to write
my likelihood function,
not as a function of theta,
but as a function of beta,
because that's the parameter
I'm actually trying to maximize.
So if I have a link--
so this thing that matters
here, I'm going to call h.
By definition, this is going
to be h of xi transpose beta.
Helena, you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Uh, no [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So this
is just all the things
that we know.
Theta is just the, by
definition of the fact that mu
is b prime of theta, the
mean is b prime of theta--
it means that theta is
b prime inverse of mu.
And then, mu is modeled from
the systematic component.
G of mu is xi transpose
beta, so this is
g inverse of xi transpose beta.
So I want to have b prime
inverse of g inverse.
This function is a
bit annoying to say,
so I'm just going to call it h.
And when I do the
composition of two inverses,
the inverse of the composition
of those two things
in the reverse order--
so h is really the inverse
of g, composed with b
prime, g of b prime inverse.
And now, if I have
the canonical link,
since I know that g
is b prime inverse,
this is really
just the identity.
As you can imagine,
this entire thing,
which is actually
quite complicated--
would just say oh, this thing,
actually, does not show up
when I have the canonical link.
I really just have that theta
can be replaced by xi of beta.
So think about going
back to this guy here.
Now, theta becomes
only xi transpose beta.
That's going to be much
more simple to optimize,
because remember, when I'm
going to log likelihood,
this thing is going to go away.
I'm going to sum those guys.
And so what I'm going to
have is something which
is essentially linear in beta.
And then, I'm going
to have this minus b,
which is just minus the sum
of convex functions of beta.
And so I'm going to have to
bring in the tools of convex
optimization.
Now, it's not just going to be
take the gradient, set it to 0.
It's going to be more
complicated to do that.
I'm going to have to do that
in an iterative fashion.
And so that's what
I'm telling you,
when you look at your
log likelihood for all
those functions.
You sum, the exponential goes
away because you had the log,
and then, you have
all these things here.
I kept the b.
I kept the h.
But if h is the identity,
this is the linear function,
the linear part, yi
times xi transpose
beta, minus b of my theta, which
is now only xi transpose beta.
And that's the function I
want to maximize in beta.
It's a convex function.
When I know what b is, I have
an explicit formula for this,
and I want to just bring
in some optimization.
And that's what
we're going to do,
and we're going to see three
different methods, which
are really, basically,
the same method.
It's just an adaptation
or specialization
of the so-called Newton-Raphson
method, which is essentially
telling you do iterative
local quadratic approximations
through your function--
so second order
[INAUDIBLE] expansion,
minimize this guy,
and then do it again
from where you were.
And we'll see that
this can be, actually,
implemented using what's called
iteratively re-weighted least
squares, which means
that every step--
since it's just
a quadratic, it's
going to be just
squares in there--
can actually be solved
by using a weighted least
squares version of the problem.
So I'm going to
stop here for today.
So we'll continue and probably
not finish this chapter,
but finish next week.
And then, I think
there's only one lecture.
Actually, for the last lecture,
what do you guys want to do?
Do you want to have
doughnuts and cider?
Do you want to just have
some more outlooking lecture
on what's happening
post 1975 in statistics?
Do you want to have a
review for the final exam--
pragmatic people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
interesting, advanced topics.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: You want
to do interesting, advanced--
for the last lecture?
AUDIENCE: Something that
we haven't thought of yet.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, that's,
basically, what I'm asking,
right-- interesting
advanced topics,
versus ask me any
question you want.
Those questions can be about
interesting, advanced topics,
though.
Like, what are interesting,
advanced topics?
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Interesting with
doughnuts-- is that OK?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, we
can always do the doughnuts.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: As long as
there are doughnuts.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: All
right, so we'll do that.
So you guys have a good weekend.